>> AND NOW A MESSAGE FROM
AMAZON'S CEO JEFF BEZOS.
>> HI, EVERYONE.
AS YOU KNOW, AMAZON JUST
ANNOUNCED THE LOCATION OF ITS
TWO NEW HEADQUARTERS IN NEW YORK
AND VIRGINIA.
AND EVERYONE, EXCEPT FOR THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE THERE AND THE
PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN ALL OF THE
PLACES WE DIDN'T CHOOSE, IS
THRILLED.
SOME FOLKS HAVE SPECULATED THAT
I WAS SOMEHOW TROLLING
PRESIDENT TRUMP BY BUILDING ONE
HEADQUARTERS IN HIS HOMETOWN OF
QUEENS AND THE OTHER IN HIS
CURRENT RESIDENCE OF WASHINGTON,
D.C., THEREBY OVERSHADOWING OR
HUMILIATING HIM.
BUT THAT'S SIMPLY NOT TRUE.
SURE, HE ATTACKED ME REPEATEDLY
ON TWITTER, BUT I CHOSE OUR NEW
LOCATIONS BECAUSE THEY WERE
IDEAL FOR A GROWING BUSINESS,
NOT JUST TO MAKE DONALD TRUMP
THINK ABOUT HOW I'M LITERALLY
100 TIMES RICHER THAN HE IS.
WE NEEDED ACCESS TO A YOUNG,
EDUCATED WORKFORCE, WHICH IS WHY
WE SET UP A SATELLITE OFFICE IN
PALM BEACH, FLORIDA, ACROSS THE
STREET FROM MAR-A-LAGO.
AND DID I PURCHASE "THE
WASHINGTON POST"?
SURE.
BUT IT WASN'T JUST TO RUN
HEADLINES LIKE THE WHITE HOUSE
IS IN A MELTDOWN OR LAWYERS
SUING "THE APPRENTICE" FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S USE OF THE
N-WORD.
AND I ALSO LIKE THE STYLE
SECTION.
BUT THE REAL REASON I WANTED TO
TALK TO YOU TODAY HAS NOTHING TO
DO WITH DONALD TRUMP, WHO
PUBLICLY ATTACKED OUR COMPANY
FOR EXPLOITING THE POST OFFICE.
I'M HERE TO ANNOUNCE A BRAND-NEW
DELIVERY OPTION THAT DOESN'T
INVOLVE THE POST OFFICE AT ALL,
AMAZON CARAVAN.
ANY PACKAGE GOING TO TRUMP'S
BUILDING WILL GET DELIVERED BY
HUNDREDS OF HONDURAN IMMIGRANTS
AND I WILL PICK UP THE BILL.
UNLESS YOU ORDER THIS BOOK,
BECAUSE THAT COSTS MORE I GUESS
IT'S HEAVIER.
I GUESS THAT'S THE ONLY BOOK
WITH FOUR CHAPTER 11S.
TESTING HAS SHOWN CUSTOMERS FIND
DRONES SCARY AND IMPERSONAL.
THAT'S WHY I'M OUTFITTING EACH
AND EVERY DRONE WITH HUMAN HAIR.
THE STYLE OF THE HAIR WAS
COMPLETELY RANDOM.
I JUST WANTED SOMETHING THAT
LOOKED SO SILLY AND EVERYBODY
KNEW IT WAS FAKE AND THE DROVE
SHOULD JUST GIVE UP AND SHAVE
HIS HEAD LIKE A REAL MAN WOULD.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE TO GIVE
BACK TO THE NEW COMMUNITIES FOR
JOINING.
THAT'S WHY I'M PURCHASING A
BUILDING IN QUEENS THAT USED TO
BE THE CROWN JEWEL OF FRED
TRUMP'S REAL ESTATE EMPIRE AND
CONVERTING IT INTO PUBLIC
URINALS.
AND IN VIRGINIA, WE'LL BE VERY
CLOSE TO ARLINGTON NATIONAL
CEMETERY SO WE CAN PAY OUR
RESPECT TO FALLEN VETERANS, EVEN
WHEN IT'S RAINING OUTSIDE.
THANKS TO MR. TRUMP, AMAZON'S
FUTURE IS BRIGHTER THAN EVER.
>> THIS HAS BEEN A SICKBURN BY
JEFF BEZOS.